llegan los refuerzos a tulum unos 450
efectivos del ejército de la armada
mexicana y de la guardia nacional
llegaron a las calles del soleado
balneario mexicano se atenderá ahorita
de manera muy puntual la situación de
tulum pero también de toda el área desde
cancún o la riviera
maya- la escalada de violencia de la
semana pasada prendió las alarmas el 21
de octubre en un tiroteo en un
restaurante murieron dos mujeres
extranjeras una alemana y una india
otros tres turistas resultaron heridos
la procuraduría de quintana roo
responsabiliza a grupos de
narcotraficantes rivales que pelean por
el territorio la presencia de tropas en
las calles causa reacciones encontradas
no es bonito ver a gente armada porque
si te intimida
mientras esté en cierto punto si sirve
si ayuda porque si pues nadie va a hacer
nada acerca de enfrente de ellos
he estado viviendo aquí durante 11 meses
tengo muchos amigos mucha gente vino
aquí porque tulum es el mejor lugar de
mexico y si la violencia ocurre en todas
partes en todas las grandes ciudades
nueva york los ángeles miami en todas
partes entonces tulum no es diferente
el sistema nacional de seguridad reportó
ochocientos sesenta y cuatro delitos
relacionados con las drogas en el estado
de quintana roo en los primeros nueve
meses del año mientras los homicidios
ascienden a diez la mayoría de ellos
impunes como los de la semana pasada en
tulum alemania no esperó avances en la
investigación para emitir un aviso de
advertencia de viajes de sus ciudadanos
a mexico